aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'école
troisièces Bazet Élancourt la filière à
cinéma d'animation et jeux vidéo va
présenter ses projets à des
professionnels
[Musique]
une journée spéciale pour la santé
d'étudiants de la filière présente ce
jour-là Loïs s’élève de 5e année à
travailler sur le jeu shift pendant 10
mois avec ses camarades à Élancourt un
jeu d'énigme de parcours en 3D dans un
univers de science-fiction
où les gens sont devenus tester nos jeux
mais c'était juste tout public là c'est
vraiment les professionnels de
l'industrie qui viennent et qui viennent
juger est-ce que nos jeux sont bons nous
faire des retours qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait améliorer qu'est-ce qui est
déjà bien et du coup on est très content
que ça se passe parce que nous bien sûr
en fin d'études on recherche aussi des
stages on recherche à se
professionnaliser et donc c'est avec des
retours de gens professionnels de
l'industrie qu'on va pouvoir se
professionnaliser et rentrer dans
l'industrie et développer enfin
commencer notre carrière une porte
ouverte qui a tiré plusieurs entreprises
ce jeudi 29 juin ils ont passé la
journée avec les étudiants inscrits de
la première année de Bachelor à la
cinquième année peut-être que tu aurais
pu faire un lien entre le sentiment que
tu voulais
faire ressentir dans chacune des pièces
et une un panel de couleur et une
direction de lumière en plus de donner
des conseils sur les différents projets
les gros studios de jeux vidéo sont
venus dénicher les nouveaux talents avec
quelque part oui on fait notre marché on
vient aussi repérer les tendances on
vient aussi repérer
la qualité de formation et
potentiellement la faire améliorer pour
la suite et c'est en ça qu'il y a une
collaboration entre les écoles et
Ubisoft l'occasion de laisser son CV
pour les étudiants certains jeux vidéo
sont déjà en discussion avec des
professionnels pour une
commercialisation une vraie réussite
pour l'école qui a relancé cette filière
depuis un an pour certains c'est la
première fois où il faisait un jeu vidéo
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez d'assez
exceptionnel parce que le résultat est
là quoi les professionnels nous le
disent reviennent vers nous ils disent
bah oui c'est réussi et en plus il faut
pas oublier que aujourd'hui à troisièces
on n'a pas encore de formation de
programmeur bon j'ai craqué alors je
vais tester un jeu créé ici dans les
studios 3IS le jeu Jean qui a été créé
par les étudiants de 5e année c'est
parti au total une dizaine de jantes été
créés ici pendant l'année
[Musique]
c'est pas mal